any rational fears in your life well I
think mines rush it would choking I
think choking is a rational fear isn't
it well isn't it I mean maybe not
oh are you scared of choking all the
time not to you because this is a bit
like therapy and I've had two gin and
tonics every time I haven't had a card
Oh every time a cut through an avocado
and I see the stone I I envisage that
stone every time I think I physically go
no I just don't have that much of a
Carter I've got a real thing now I've
got a real thing about choking I mean if
you're on your own you're on a hotel you
know if you're just it could take days
to find out has it happened - yes I've
choked to death many times you have
choked food
yeah and it's scary it's horrible
somebody did somebody just larger one
time they did actually it was I did that
show Never Mind the Buzzcocks and one
time I'd had too many whose crisps
there's on a pig and I like eating
crisps as quickly as possible so who
would these crisps down and they weren't
ready to go down and they got lodged and
so I had a beer in my hand and I was
like doing that and people go and so I
had this beer it sort of all came out
and Forte's thank god someone an actor
called Andy smart who are known for
years got behind me and did the Heimlich
maneuver and I was very very grateful
because as I understand it if you can
still breathe or talk then it's it's in
the it's in the safe pop or cough or yes
yeah then you're not going to die but it
feels very scary when you've got
something lodged in your that's happened
to me a few times last time after he was
at Andy circuses house wait a minute
that's happened to you
it's Christmas what what to
Chris Wood's like a donor
it's a to chips oh oh yeah yeah Jagat
they're a big target dude swallow them
whole or do you would think not
yeah yeah you would think not I know I
do definitely chew but um just ate too
much not enough yes I'm in such a hurry
to get that crispy flavor I can't wait
for your obituary
he'd been warned many times
[Laughter]
[Music]